au nord-ouest de madagascar l'île de
nosy komba est une destination prisée
des touristes avec 45000 visiteurs par
an si l'on prend en compte la
fréquentation de l'île voisine de nocibé
la région serait particulièrement
exposée en cas d'épidémie car la petite
île volcanique accessible seulement
pirogue ne compte pas d'hôpital le suivi
médical et seulement assurée par un
généraliste et une sage-femme au sein
d'un dispensaire en pleine pandémie
mondiale
nos six combats doit donc se prémunir
contre les risques présentés par
l'arrivée de touristes venus de zones à
risque dont les hôtels les employés
appliquent les consignes sanitaires
à leur arrivée les touristes doivent se
présenter à l'équipe médicale est un
généraliste décide de la nécessité ou
pas de procéder à un dépistage avec
seulement 100 kits de test rapide
disponible sur l'île voisine de nocibé
seuls les touristes arrivés avant la
fermeture des frontières
ils ont été contraints cette semaine
trois ressortissants français en
provenance de la réunion ont fait
l'objet d'un dépistage
ces touristes ont été testés négatifs
ils ont donc pu sortir de la quarantaine
décidées par le gouvernement malgache
des mesures de précaution que ces
touristes ont volontiers accepté pour
gagner la confiance de la population
je pense que ça va bien rassuré tout le
monde le fait qu'on se prête au jeu bas
de la quarantaine déjà et qui a depuis
le test à chaque fois qu'on a été
convoqué par le trou vivons à respecter
les différentes directives et ça s'est
bien rassuré le village et ça nous a
permis d'accepter respecter pour ça je
pense donc à contraire serait pas été
bon pour nous je pense
on a discuté avec des gens qui sont un
outil dès qu'ils sont une tension que
vous avez ressenti réellement à part le
premier soit après la quarantaine on est
sorti enfin pas de velours
est ce que c'est bon ça le fait ce que
les gens ont peur de nous qui ont fait
ça fait il des contrées pour l'heure il
lit les préserver du coville 19 et
entend bien le rester mais elle subit
tout de même les conséquences de
l'épidémie compter de la majorité de ses
revenus touristiques depuis près d'un
mois
nos six combats s'enfonce peu à peu dans
la crise économique